le super bowl c'est la journée des
publicités télévisées et les marques
mettent le paquet pour marquer les
esprits
mieux vaut bien pensé à son concept
quand on paie plus de 7 millions de
dollars pour 30 secondes de diffusion
surtout que les marques misent encore
une fois cette année sur de grandes
vedettes américaines pour vanter leurs
mérites et les spectateurs verront total
une cinquantaine de publicités
différentes
et comme d'habitude les constructeurs
automobiles sont très présents tout
comme les marques de bière et les géants
numérique comme amazon le réseau
américain fox a vendu tous ses espaces
publicitaires ce qui représente des
revenus d'environ 600 millions de
dollars
[Musique]